you were born here
raised here
this Dome is the only World you've ever
known
as a place just off past the Eastern
Ridge
right there dad what are you talking
about you'll see
get out there
the crater
whatever's out there your dad wants you
to see it we've never even been outside
the Dome before
so what's it gonna be we're leaving
tonight I hear
why
so the peculiar you're peculiar all in
favor
let's go steal her over
the lockdown will commence
you know the best thing about road trips
everything behind
here it is bottom of the night the wind
up
foreign
[Music]
isn't really blue yeah
most important thing to remember this is
a bad idea
it's not just about where you're going
meteor shower Madison run it's about how
you get there
the people you get there with Caleb
what's in the crater I don't know
guess we'll find out you guys go first
you're never quite the same as you were
when you began
the days of my life
[Music]